[Applause]
what we are seeing is histor earlier
today 10,000 American Jews traveled from
across the country to protest on the
National Mall we came to DC to raise our
voices in the largest protest of Jews
and supportive Palestinians in history
to call on Congress to support the
ceasefire now resolution
there are about 400 people who have
occupied the Cannon Building less now
because many of them were
[Music]
[Applause]
arrested and thousands more rallied
outside we are with you we are with you
do not be afraid do not be we
got we have over 400 American Jews in
our allies here occupying the cannon
building and we will not leave because
we are here demanding an end to the
genocide of the Palestinian people in
Gaza so we had thousands of people who
dropped everything in the middle of
their work week um to come here um I
think about 400 maybe more people who
risked arrest and who have been arrested
we have about 25 left I think civil
disobedience is part of how we get
messages across and we need the Congress
to hear we need the president to hear
that the American Jewish Community is
not a monolith and that many of us are
here to stand up for Gaza and they need
to do the
[Music]
same we need to call for a ceasefire we
need humanitarian Aid we need to stop
sending money stop stationing troops
this is not a Time the US government has
a lot of power in this situation and
needs to do its job and right now it is
escalating we need deescalation and that
is our message the bombing of Gaza uh
area that is has 2.2 million people
contained in an area smaller than
Detroit with their water and electricity
turned off without access to life-saving
Medical Aid these people are trapped in
an open air prison while bombs continue
to rain overhead and white phosphorus
fills the sky we are here as Jews to say
not in our name as a people who have
survived genocide we are rising up in
the way that we wish others would have
spoken up for our own Community to do
everything that we can to risk
everything that we have to stop a
genocide from unfolding in real time
against the Palestinian people in Gaza
hundreds and hundreds of people are
arrested and we will continue to to be
here because we know that we cannot have
a genocide it is it is a moral
catastrophe
and rather than joining us they're
they're arresting us and we think that
any person no matter who you are with
moral Integrity will call for an end to
this genocide I think the IDF has a
history of lying and painting all
Palestinians is terrorists and that is
fundamentally false I know I know
Palestinian citizens right now who who
literally like they talk to me on the
phone crying in between crying losing
sleep and and praying um because their
loved ones are were bombed by the IDF so
I think of course the IDF is going to
lie about it they want to they want to
act like everybody's a terrorist and
that's just fundamentally not true we
believe that every human every life is
precious our tradition teaches us B
Salam Elohim we were all made in the
image of God Palestinians Israelis but
the truth is our government doesn't fund
tamas it funds Israel and that's who
it's funding right now to commit war
crimes it's so deeply disturbing that
the president has chosen chosen to
travel to Israel and embrace prime
minister Netanyahu pledging him money
and Military Support for their continued
bombing of Gaza the fact that Biden went
over to Israel in a show of support for
the Israeli government when they're in
the middle of um just
mercilessly bombing and dispossessing
people is just absolutely inappropriate
for the United States to play the fact
that they're sending an additional $10
billion of Aid to Israel to enable them
to continue this military campaign is
absolutely appalling and I want Biden to
listen to the voices of thousands and
thousands and thousands of Jews and lots
of other people too who are saying that
this war is absolutely wrong in the
United States should not be supporting
it Biden needs to stand up and help
facilitate a ceasefire so no more people
die innocent people are dying and being
deprived of water Medical Care and food
every second that we wait in
[Applause]
Gaza